she tweets Jack Smith errantly claimed
that Trump was a Flight Risk to convince
judge Beryl Howell to prevent Trump from
knowing about the Twitter search warrant
Meryl Howell agreed that Trump would
flee from prosecution writing the
district court also found reason to
believe the former president would flee
from prosecution the government later
acknowledged however that it errantly
included flight from prosecution as a
predicate in its application
they have already laid the groundwork to
remand Trump to custody under the under
the idea that he will flee if they try
to uh to convict him and so this is what
I was saying before
if the charges against Donald Trump are
legitimate if they genuinely believe it
Trump would be locked up right now they
would not let him leave the man on
several Jets helicopters he's a
billionaire he has buildings with his
name on it he owns buildings all over
the world he could go to any one of
these countries he has the absolute
capabilities to flee the only reason he
wouldn't is because he's running for
president but they have made the
argument already we're getting this
information out of the the the Twitter
revelation
that they're trying to seek information
from his Twitter account
they're they're actually arguing now
that Trump's going to try and fully so
how long until they were man him to
custody how long until they make the
argument that Trump should not be free
and then they stop him from campaigning
I don't know I thought that they were
not gonna do that this is this just came
out today that they arantly included
flight from prosecution as a as a
predicate what does that mean they
accidentally had his his Flight Risk in
there and then they took it out I think
they what they're saying is they did not
mean to include that they feel that
Trump is a Flight Risk when facing
prosecution
yeah like what do you don't make
accidents at that level maybe maybe they
do maybe they do actually I don't know
but it seems like a convenient accident
to have that piece of data on and off
the Record at the same time I think
they're gonna lock him up they're trying
to silence him Trump's fighting back can
he still run if they lock him up yes but
he's not gonna be able to go to rallies
I mean it sounds kind of fun though I'm
kind of interested in that idea yeah I
think if they lock him up he still wins
in fact I think I think it helps him
exactly I think they know putting him in
jail is gonna give him a a major victory
look if Elon Musk is right that is the
funniest outcome like he gets arrested
and then goes to jail and then wins and
pardons himself and pardons all the
guards and then goes to DC that would be
hilarious yes but there are there are
many people
throughout history who have been jailed
by the by their their government or
political Rivals and then later get out
and then win Hitler is the first one
that comes to say Hitler I was gonna say
Mandela Mandela's the other one Napoleon
was uh banished and then he came back
and went right back to the Revolution
and started attacking again yep I don't
know man I think there's a strong
possibility they lock up Trump
they're throwing everything and the
kitchen sink I think it'd be hilarious
they would piss off 100 million people
if they did that like Beyond yeah you
just that would be the worst tactic
maybe that's the real conspiracy theory
that Trump really is the the you know
the trigger no that's the war no that
Trump is deep State and in order to get
him to win with the support of the
people you need to make him into the
Martyr into the victim that people are
willing to get behind interesting it's
not that hard to imagine though if you
think about like so just do a thought
experiment with me for a second imagine
if Joe Biden had been president in 2020
do you think all those red Governors
would have locked their states down
yeah
um they were they would have been on the
opposite side they would have said oh no
you know yeah they would have been like
resisting the tyranny of Joe Biden where
with Donald Trump saying hey guys we got
to do this you know all the red States
kind of like okay whatever so we're
slowly starting to turn around yeah but
the the argument would be
how do you get a Libertarian to vote for
a Republican president
no you make him the Martyr you make him
you make him the persecuted you make him
the anti-establishment you make him the
anti-government I was talking about this
with Bitcoin I was like you know if I
was a world economic Forum globalist
billionaire and I wanted a One World
Currency how would I do it because we've
heard that conspiracy over and over
again they're gonna they're gonna make a
One World Government currency you know
Alex Jones have been talking about it
for decades I'm like well
you got to get the crackpot conspiracy
theorists to be the ones pushing and
advocating for it
because you come out against them then
you get that whole network of people
paying attention to politics they're
against you and they don't wanna they
don't want to do it so then I see
Bitcoin and all of a sudden I see the
likes of these Anarchist
anti-establishment conspiracy theorist
types all saying it's the future and you
have to use it
and I'm like so this this you're calling
it I don't know if they call it a
currency these days or whatever but it's
like Global financial transaction system
that can be tracked by anyone at any
point right and they can know everything
you're doing
and y'all are advocating for I'm like
that's this is like a one world unified
currency
well I mean you know I'm like I'm not
saying that that's true I'm just saying
if you want a One World Currency
Bitcoins or I should just say crypto in
general is a fast path
especially considering they can track
everything you're buying yeah I'm a gold
bug so Phil's gotta defend Bitcoin
uh I mean I'm I'm
a fan of Bitcoin as well as gold and
silver and I've got a little bit of all
that stuff I'm not a one a one-way kind
of dude
that sounds a little that the guys in
town in uh and Tower gang are gonna pay
are gonna punish me for that I like that
you can create your own crypto and use
it like locally for things even though
the government would want to take taxes
from you you can still do it and like
things like someone just texted Monero
uh Gustav said that in the chat yeah
Monero apparently is untrackable or more
challenging what happens like that what
happens when they tell Trump
they say where are you currently
residing it says Bedminster New Jersey
they say okay don't leave the state
what what about that that's a half
scenario it's like they're not jailing
them because they don't want to give
them any any hard political martyr
benefits you probably would not leave
the state go nuts on social media
they're not letting me leave the state
this is unconscionable I'm stuck here in
this beautiful palace in Bedminster you
know but I think he would stay there and
just do a lot more media I have social
media I don't know
if he went he said that he was in
Florida I imagine he couldn't get he
wouldn't get remanded to
uh it's going to be a federal judge who
says like we're going to release you but
you have to stay in a certain area
because we want to make sure that you
don't flee blah blah blah Maybe
I do want to see this though I want to
see Trump arrested what I want Trump or
Amanda to custody I think I think when
the fact that they arrested him and let
him go proves they're lying about
everything
like they're accusing the guy of trying
to overthrow the government and they're
like yeah you can go go do whatever you
want yeah so what I find interesting is
they can't you know prosecute him for
war crimes because they'd be complicit
in the same things they tried to go
after you know they got to go after
Biden Obama Bush Clinton no boy we can
go all the way back and the like the let
them go thing is like we think you did a
crime but you can go it's kind of like
here take this package whatever you do
don't take it across the street to that
7-Eleven don't do it and then they just
watch and they're waiting waiting for
him to take the package across the
street they're like we just want you to
flee man we just want you to do
something to give us an excuse to crack
down a hundred times harder
he can fly wherever he wants
so do you do you think Trump will put
his foot down on Ukraine because he yes
the again I I judge a man by what he
does not what he says and you know to
his credit he did talk to Putin and he
kept an open line of communication for
the most part but he also
was the guy who initiated lethal Aid to
Ukraine Obama like he even bragged Obama
was only sending pillows and helmets or
something like that I'm sending them
missiles and I mean he he was
responsible for a lot of the escalation
he tore up the INF treaty the open Skies
treaty you know so I don't know like I I
just don't believe what people say I
believe I do I think I think the war
ends the moment when he gets elected
yeah I think Putin is going to ceasefire
and then he's gonna say we're waiting
and Trump's gonna go and I think a
likely scenario if Trump did get elected
is the Don bass goes to uh Russia Crimea
and the donbass go to Russia Ukraine
retains everything else fighting stops I
mean I would like to think that could
happen because it's a very low bar like
all we got to do is stop sending
billions of dollars and the war ends
which the media is even starting to
admit that now like Boris Johnson went
there and disrupted peace peace
agreements so yeah NATO countries want
they want war yeah I mean look I think
many in the west United States
particular particularly are saying this
is our chance to it's a castle spelling
for war with Russia we needed a way to
justify war with Russia and now we have
it but Russia needs to push harder
Russia needs to attack a NATO country so
that NATO can invade Russia that's what
they want to happen
and they'll keep doing it until Russia
has no choice I wouldn't be surprised if
you get NATO military forces firing from
inside NATO territory at Russians
you've already got a story about a
Russian strike that it was 600 feet from
Romania or something like that so we're
getting dangerously close
Donald Trump is going to go in and be
like nope no more fighting he's going to
go to the you he's gonna go to Ukraine
but you're not getting any more money
from us and they're going to go okay we
want peace no more funding no more
military you they're not going to be
able to support any any effort against
Russia how entangled do you think the
Deep state is with this war right now
how much vested interest do they have in
seeing it 100 then they'll assassinate
him if he tries to stop it I I see one
thing you you mean to say they'll try
they'll try they'll try over and over
and over and over and over one big
problem with your theory I have is uh
Lindsey Graham how close that guy still
is with Trump I mean he is like the
epitome of everything we're talking
about
I think
Donald Trump Wants Revenge too much
when he goes in he is going to be just
screaming at the top of his lungs
I'm not saying it's absolute I'm just
saying what they've done to him now
assuming it's all on the level rating
his house going after his family
whatever he's he's gonna go and he's
going to scream at these people he's
going to be like you're weak you stabbed
me in the back Lindsey Graham sure maybe
but Lindsey Graham what's he doing to
help Trump right now nothing these guys
abandoned with him a little bit Yeah
they but they abandon him across the
board so Donald Trump may be not perfect
there's a strong possibility you get a
bunch of BS but I'll you know I'll flip
the coin I think there's a good the best
candidate right now for firing people in
government hey maybe it's one guy I'll
take it it's gonna be Trump no I don't
think so I think it's fake because he
talks about you can't literally fire
people uh you can shut down
um like sectors of the of the government
where people work and then their jobs
are dissipated and they no longer work
there you can't do individual firings
um Trump didn't know that apparently
when he was in office he's like I can't
fire them but he could have shut shut
them down and he didn't I I think he's
not in a good I don't know I don't want
to assume too much but it seems like
Trump's not in a very good State of Mind
relative to 2016 when he was like we're
gonna make America great he was talking
about making things great now he's
talking about like I'm gonna go get him
you let me back in there I'm gonna get
him Revenge I don't want that I mean in
2016 he talked about the Federal Reserve
and the bubble economy we've created and
how lowering interest rates artificially
is going to cause problems and then as
soon as he became president without
addressing any of it it was instantly
the greatest economy in the world
everything's fine you know so he has a
way of talking about the problems when
he's not in there and then as soon as he
gets in he has awful people you know
talking him up and you know schmoozing
him and everything and then he just kind
of I don't know he listens to bad advice
a lot I feel like his instincts are
better than the the governing he's done
but you know he's just he he likes
flattery he likes being worshiped so
that's so dangerous thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time